[Music]
they might have come here to the United
States because they were refugees but
they're asked where they're from they
say I'm from Houston they think of
themselves as American kids they see
themselves as soccer players that is
their primary identity that's who they
are
[Music]
to achieve a state championship would be
to announce to the entire community that
this group of kids is great it's not
just that they're not bad they're great
I've worked in youth services for 30
years my whole career soccer is the
single best intervention tool that I
have ever had the reason I heard from my
friend he told me that this place that
we play something so like next time when
you go just let me know so I can come
with you we were exploring the need like
what what does this community need we
began by just having pickup games on the
soccer field on Sunday afternoon and so
the kids that showed up many of whom
came here from Africa four or less years
ago had never played on an organized
team one time we said next week we'll
get pizza and double the number of kids
came like it was obvious when they were
eating they had not eaten since probably
school got out on Friday I had no
intention at all of forming a team but
that was when the light bulb went off
there's more here
my name is Francois Ellis and I'm the
captain of this team I'm Jeffrey vanilla
I'm a forward Dominick Azera
people gonna be full moon on Danny David
jumbo my name is Luther Shabani in a
play right wing provision of see I left
Congo when I was 2 years old then after
five years we went to a refugee camp in
Kakuma is called Kakuma refugee camp and
we stayed there for seven to eight years
life in refugee camp is tough everybody
and Uganda and Congo was like oh my god
I wish I can go to United States so when
my mom passed the interview like big
news for us of the funny when you look
in the fourth world country you never
think of United State being like this oh
my thought when I come with your Emma be
safe no violence
everything good but when we come over
the same thing at first I thought well
like if you get of you know like have an
own house you know how my car but he was
allowed be different welcome home I was
born into his onion yellow ghost refugee
camp
my mom ran away from war from Congo
Hugh and returns a Nicole should not
leave place that des wort Aleta is the
life of the party he comes from the most
difficult circumstances of any of the
internet I used to live with my mom my
grandmother my uncles we used to live at
the same place he was like 12 of them
including me I used to cry like he said
tell my man where he and Final Four she
like could have anything to buy so you
have to wait sometimes you know you're
gonna just drink water the whole day
they just don't make enough money
there's there's no way that she can make
enough money to support the family and
yet elute is is just full of joy all the
time constantly and it's infectious
everybody feels it what I'm really proud
of him is that he's like the father in
the family taking care of the kids is
not an easy job for a parent who is
disabled he's there to help her out I
[Music]
started playing soccer when I was 7
years old I used to play in Africa
and whenever I'm in a soccer field I
feel like I'm somewhere out of peace
when I'm in the soccer field what he
manages to overcome on a daily basis and
yet to meet the world with that level of
joy is it's unprecedented I've never
seen a kid like that before
he's what it's all about
[Music]
the level of anxiety that these kids and
their parents and their families just
carry around on a regular basis is
intense it's overwhelming and I think
that's part of what the success on the
field has been they need a release but
sometimes when I'm stressed think about
like how we're gonna deal with eating
bills having my mom every time I get in
a soccer field
I'd be happy like I forgot everything
it's really easy to get burned together
cause we all know the struggles you know
imagine and go V dummies unity staying
together as a team doing everything as a
team that's what makes us even more
stronger revision is gonna be called FC
Texas you know because we're gonna win
the stake up
[Music]
the state cup is the highest level of
u.s. youth soccer this season we had the
goal to earn a berth in the state Cup
but we weren't sure if we were gonna be
capable because there were some teams
that were very strong you know Barcelona
Real Madrid is that's how he was
and coach start telling us keep pushing
like give everything you got so we can
win it me stepping in the field we had a
lot of racism
[Music]
you can talked with the ball you told me
go back to your country you don't have
to stay here I just play and two minutes
I scored two goals I was like they don't
say anymore
handshake is something like everybody do
to show respect at the end of one of the
games we wanted to show respect and so
we just wanted to shake hands with them
about the parents of all like after the
game there was talking miss no saying
the [ __ ] keys
sometimes they call you monkey you know
monkey monkey and they say you do touch
my kid I'm like which it's a game first
why he's the one that was telling them
like the just kids they just here to
have fun just the same way you and your
kids wanna have fun I took the guys and
took him away all the way way off the
field I set them down and I said that
I'm sorry that you had to go through
that but unfortunately I can't protect
you from that I wish I could but this is
America and racism is real we're not
there for fighting or heading we there
for like one goal win
that's only one
[Music]
we have a group chat which is bubbling
all the time
coach texting a group site was like guys
I know we playing a strong team tomorrow
but I believe thee I believe you can do
this know like yes coach
no we can do this it means a lot was for
him to believe in us cause we've come a
long way nobody's ever really taught us
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's standing between us and the state
Cup is this game so let's focus on this
game put everything else out of your
mind we can do this I believe now is the
time
[Music]
I think everybody needs to have a
reminder that brightness doesn't
necessarily correlate with where you're
from or how you grew up or how much
money you have greatness can rise from
the grass roots from the ground up and
be more beautiful than you ever imagined
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that experience of coming to the United
States through an application to the
Immigration Service as a refugee that is
not the salient identity that they have
today they are successful soccer players
they are college students or future
college students they are successful
young adults
when I come here there was not thinking
now I'm a champion bull now I'm a state
champion
I'm really really proud because when you
win stay like you next level me it'll
feel is the best feeling ever
the Americans I think this is a
beginning you coming hard I believe
that's our
[Music]
I have see buying corn to my teammates
and our all born in different countries
I was born in Ghana and raised in Canada
Torrington was born and raised in France
we played in Germany do you guys know
the Nutmeg challenge the Panna you know
a circle 101 try to pun on your friend
okay come from all over speaking in
different languages celebrating
different traditions but above all we
are citizens of football we speak
football we valued football it makes you
teammates with the rest of the world to
see these guys in America playing
together so far from home and now
calling Houston home because of this
family is the beautiful game for Miami
man yeah this is of an applet for vision
and some happy mirin where you from I
live in Houston yeah I don't know I need
a video
[Applause]
[Music]